hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast vibration noise and ultrasonic
noise from vivarium and lab equipment as
rapidly growing compounds and animal
research presented by dr. jeremy turner
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries to learn more about lab routes
please visit WWE Champion tiara boat of
science labs and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem now I'd like to
introduce dr. jeremy turner dr. Turner
is co-founder and CEO of auto science
labs in Jacksonville Illinois and also a
professor at Illinois College he has
been conducting research on hearing in
mice and rats for 20 years and has
received funding from the tinnitus
research research consortium National
Institutes of Health and most recently
the Department of Defense psychological
health and traumatic brain injury
program his current research focus
includes aiding animal research
facilities in the measurement of noise
and vibration and animal spaces and
helping others to better understand the
effects of these variables on biomedical
research in 2007 dr. Turner was asked to
be a guest editor of a special issue of
jalis which centered around the issue of
noise and vibration in animal research
facilities please join me in welcoming
dr. Turner I'll now turn the
presentation
okay welcome everyone thanks for tuning
in and we'll get started I'm planning on
sharing some information with you for 40
to 45 minutes maybe and leaving a good
10 or 15 minutes for questions and
answers so please submit those questions
so the main focus today is to begin
understanding the the impacts of noise
and vibration and animal facilities what
it can do to our biomedical research in
a variety of areas and traditionally we
have worried about this for the last 20
years as it impacts the hearing research
that I do on the hearing research
scientist and have been so for quite a
while studying how rats here have mice
here how we use them in models for for
human hearing so I'm interested in the
stress impact of noise and vibration the
basic the basic structure then for what
we're gonna do today
this this for me this adventure got
started in around oh five when we put
together a review article on the
auditory and non auditory effects of
noise on research animals and this was
basically an opportunity to share with
non hearing researchers what what their
animals heard and why why it would
impact them in various ways pointing out
for example that a lot of the strains of
mice we use or our death or near death
and that the sounds that are in their
environments may or may not impact them
because of their hearing range and and
various factors that we'll get into
today in 2007 we actually were able to
put together a special issue of JLS so
you can still get access to that I
encourage you to do it because there are
some remarkable chapters in there on
acoustics and ultrasonic communication
and how sound is measured in things of
that sort but the bottom line is that
noise matters and vibration matters and
it doesn't matter whether you're looking
at cancer or diabetes or immune system
responses these variables serve as
compounds for the research that that we
do and we need to understand them so
this is basically a summary of what
we're going to talk about this is a
so what we're going to see noise the
vibration experienced by our animals
impacts every area of biomedical
research and I hope I can give that to
you today
so as you're having conversations with
colleagues with pis with others in the
facility recognize that this is not just
about people who study hearing and
people who study vibration that once
stress systems are impacted you can
impact the entire organism its behavior
its brain function it's remarkably
important and under studied noise
ultrasonic noise and vibration they're
present in every research facility we've
been to we've measured for many
facilities in laboratory spaces it's
ubiquitous
it's everywhere these compounds are and
the variability from institution to
institution is great from the vivarium
room to room is great and even within
the same room we see major variability
in noise and vibration from rat Dirac
from location to location within a
library room so understanding these
measures are critical to gaining and
control our 3 R's actually so these
Stingley have their wide-ranging impact
because of the stress they induce on
animals it's not because it's causing
hearing loss in them and that's been a
traditional concern we'll talk about why
that is momentarily the bottom line here
is that it ends up causing us to use
many more animals than we have to
imagine for a second a scenario whereby
you've got two racks of mice in the same
vivarium room one rack is shooting off
an ultrasonic noise that's stressful and
the and it is also vibrating violently
because of the rack top motor going bad
on the top and the rack right beside
that rack is not and you're putting
those same animals into the same study
and you're seeing high variability you
have to use more animals you can't
repeat studies from lab to lab that
noopy I move to your facilities like I
can't repeat anything I found in my last
job so it makes for a major major
frustration among pis and of course the
facility you know director had that and
staff they get blamed for for these
problems even though it's not clear
whether they're even
so one of the bottom-line messages is
that we need to start measuring this
it's as important as measuring whether
the lights are on or off we would go
crazy if we didn't know whether the
lights were on or off in our facility it
would go crazy if we didn't know what
ingredients were in the food that we
give the animals we would go crazy if we
didn't know you know what organisms are
sentinels were exposed to but we don't
go crazy because noise and vibration for
some reason we're not interested enough
in this problem we don't understand it
well enough to begin measuring it so we
think we should start measuring this
routinely
and in fact once you find a problem it's
pretty easy to fix it identify whether
it's noise or vibration it actually can
be used as a really good measure of the
health of your equipment whether you're
talking about lights or motors it's
routine actually to use noise and
vibration as measures of condition
monitoring status if you're in an
industrial setting for example you can
measure the acoustics of a motor and
tell whether it's going bad we can do
this it's it's not that hard and it
impacts our animals in very negative
ways so a major point to recognize here
and some of you of course do recognize
this but I want to note that what
animals hear we're going to start with
hearing today and then with the
vibration what animals here compared to
what we hear is very different so if you
look at this plot this was adapted from
that 2007 five paper that we that we did
what we have here is basically the
hearing range of people and so we people
can hear sounds from one or two hundred
Hertz my voice is around hundred fifty
Hertz for example right through here
right through this point is where my
voice is going to be unfortunately if
you look carefully the mouse in red and
the rat in orange these guys these are
their curves way out here they hear
these really high pitches that we don't
hear actually anything above 12 or 15
kilohertz it has to be pretty loud for
us to hear it and so the problem here of
course then is that all the equipment in
our
these a lot of it is generating noise up
here that we don't hear and it's it's
impacting our animals and they're
communicating up there and we don't even
know it in fact if you're just looking
at a human voice range the the mouse for
example right here has a really hard
time hearing a male voice some harmonics
and a female voice can bounce up here in
the mouse can hear some harmonics in a
male voice as well but ultimately the
mouse doesn't hear the human voice very
well at all so this an important point
to keep in mind we're also talk about
how the sound up here these high
frequency sounds they behave differently
than the sounds down here these low
frequency sounds bounce around corners
they go under doors they move easily
these high frequency sounds are very
directional in nature so once we find
one we can actually cut it out you can
deflect it we can do various things to
promis-- its impact so again this is the
human speech range and this is the rat
and mouse speech range for lack of a
better word this is where they vocalize
this is where they communicate if you
want to stress out a rat or a mouse
you're going to use a sound up here it's
really effective these these different
animals abilities to process these
different sounds doesn't just happen by
chance it's because they actually use
them to communicate so these are
actually vocalizations from from from
rats these are from Sprague Dawley rats
and notice the sound frequency here
remember we people we people only hear
up to about this 20 kilohertz line right
here right so this sound down here we
can hear up here we can't these rats are
talking to one another they're
communicating much more is known today
about rat vocalizations and mouse
vocalizations and why they're used and
how they're used
we have no idea that they're
communicating and whether you house them
individually or in groups or same-sex
groups or opposite sex groups you can
get very different vocalizations the
point is that sounds up their matter to
them and so when we have those present
in the environment it can be intrusive
mice similar story these are just
different panels from that oh seven
journal review that we did this is by
Christine cork floors really beautiful
calls that mice exhibit high frequencies
and you can see of course that mice
we've all heard it mice will squeal to
in the range really low frequency range
that we can hear but they they have all
this beautiful complex high frequency
responses out there that they admit so
these high frequency sounds if they're
present they can be problematic for
animals the guide starting in this last
edition really began to take this issue
seriously so there are several places in
the guide where this has brought out
four million vibration and in particular
ultrasonic noise is mentioned more and
more and so I just want to point out
three of these locations in the guide
where this is brought up and I'm gonna
underline the shoot statements because
they're important the point to this this
location in the guy who existed in
Chapter three or focus on fireman
housing and management the point here is
that many species can hear sounds that
we can't these ultrasonic sounds and
they can come from equipment like the
computer screens lights lots of anything
mechanical ultimately in the in the
vivarium space that would be research
equipment as well as rack top blowers
cage changing stations those can serve
as ways to introduce noise and
ultrasonic noise and vibration actually
and should therefore be carefully
considered so the equipment that you're
using you need to take into account the
hearing in those animals under the
physical plant section in Chapter five
the point here is that the location of
equipment is important obviously we're
possibly you want to select equipment
for facilities that does not generate
ultrasonic noise unfortunately most
equipment manufactures don't provide any
documentation about whether their
equipment does this so they're almost at
the mercy of you know whatever you have
available so it's you basically have to
measure it ultimately that it should be
considered and then finally in Chapter
five point here is that when you're
dealing with the building structure
when you're dealing with building a new
structure or doing remodeling you
ultimately want to make sure that you
understand the equipment the HVAC all
the potential sources of noise
ultrasonic noise and vibration and
isolate them from the animals as best
you could so obviously in a perfect
world we've put all of the mechanical
equipment in an interstitial space you
know on the other side of the wall and
that that's not always practical or
possible but we should be selecting our
materials based on these principles we
should be designing and choosing
components that minimize these factors
we should be doing more that is the
point and I actually think that in the
not-too-distant future it's going to be
expected that every facility provides
some documentation of the noise and
vibration metrics and their facility
just like it's important that you log
you know that they light timers
Weatherly wrong twelve twelve and what
time they're on at what time they're off
I think noise and vibration is is
equally as important one of the problems
with noise is that as we talk to people
about this they think that the only
problem with noise is that it causes
hearing loss and this couldn't be
further from the truth
the noise does in fact cause hearing
loss but only only if the noise is up
above this level here so what this slide
shows us is how intense sound is and we
worry about anything about 85 dB so if
you're exposed to an 85 DB noise for an
eight-hour workday OSHA says you've got
to be careful this can actually cause
permanent hearing loss we actually see
in a lot of high variance spaces noises
at this level or higher in cage changing
stations and in fact we've been in some
facilities where the racks that are
closest to cage changing stations or
ragtop lowers can actually have sounds
of 90 95 DB
present and that can actually cause
hearing loss in those animals definitely
can cause stress but more importantly
for the present talk is the recognition
that it's actually the sounds down here
that are known to cause stress we all
know that if a vacuum cleaner is running
around us if that were there all day
every day that would drive you crazy
and yet you know if we have a 75 DB
signal coming from a rack top lower all
day
we don't even know it's there sometimes
conversation 60 DB living in city urban
residents was traffic outside 50 DB so
the point is that while these sounds
aren't loud enough to cause hearing loss
they are loud enough to activate stress
pathways and can do so in really
dramatic ways we are very concerned
about these noises and I actually come
at the study of noise and vibration from
you know hearing research side of course
but I study specifically tinnitus so I'm
interested in leaning in the ears in
rats and mice so we model tinnitus in a
lot of people as basically a form of
inescapable noise exposure that causes
stress and so we are ringing in the ears
you may sympathize with this and we're
effectively giving our animals tinnitus
that is in the environment it's not in
their head when we have these sources of
sound in their environment not good not
good if they're going into a
cardiovascular study a stress response
to idea immune system study huge
confound and I won't get into this very
much but just recognize that ultimately
when sound comes in it activates full
networks entire the entire brain becomes
activated if you really want to stress
out an animal you can use noise and
vibration in fact a lot of people who
study stress for a living
use noise and vibration as stressors for
their animals for their animal models it
has wide-ranging neurological impacts
and then behavioral impacts on any
number of other metrics there's a lot
more information on this elsewhere by
the way anybody who has any additional
questions I can answer them offline or
send you papers they can fill in the
detail so a couple of summary points
here these are some of the non auditory
effects of sound and live animals just a
small sampling of them we know it can
increase blood pressure heart rate do
all kinds of cardiovascular things to
animals it can activate lots of stress
hormones and other neuro chemical
pathways but it can impact breeding it
can change estrus cycle it can alter
fertility rates change we
significant things via reproductive
processes so when you notice animals not
greeting when you notice them behaving
differently start to look for noise and
vibration as concerned interestingly a
lot of these same things that we see
with noise we see in vibration so
they're very similar in fact noise is a
vibration in the air ultimately so
they're really the same basic phenomenon
it's just a matter of whether it's
propagated in the air or in solid
substance we actually know quite a bit
about the effects of noise on non
auditory systems from people actually
this is one of those areas where we
learn more from people that we can apply
to our models a lot of the performance
issues that we see with low levels of
noise we we know from human work so for
example if you're if you're at a
workstation and we have a fan on your
computer that's not that that's that's
pretty loud we can show that you
actually will have more errors than the
person in the next room who doesn't have
a lot of computer
these can be 45 DB or 50 DB loud these
are really relatively quiet sounds but
they're enough to activate stress
pathways and you're not even aware of it
you don't process it as stress but your
body does so it can impact attention
performance irritability mood all kinds
of decision-making processes can be
impacted and it doesn't you know is not
a stretch for us all to imagine if we're
ever trying to work in a relatively
noisy and complex environment it's very
difficult to do that in any kind of
advanced cognitive way it impacts our
sleep so a lot of the animal models
obviously we're we're not monitoring you
know them 24 hours a day so we don't
know what they're exposed to we're not
there we know that when we're in there
working we're creating a lot of noise
and vibration but and of course often
times you know this is going to be a
part of the day women when they're
actually asleep you know during a light
phase so their sleep becomes disrupted
major time by the noise and vibrations
that are in their environments
that too much try to move on here so we
need to distinguish between macro and
micro noise and actually the same goes
with vibration so the sources of macro
noise will include you know cage washers
down the hall or across the hall the
wheels on carts that you use to
transport bedding into the room or
animals in and out the doors and their
closers whether they squeak whether it
shakes the room the middle row shots the
ventilation system the lights
fluorescent lighting and LED lights
actually can can produce ultrasonic
noise and and we can measure this pretty
easily any electronic equipment in the
vivarium space and in the laboratory can
can create noise that we don't hear and
this is frightening actually it's
actually much more dramatic in
laboratory spaces in our experience when
we go to a facility the vibrating spaces
are relatively clean because we don't
have oscilloscopes and tons of computers
and all kinds of behavioral testing
control computers that you walk into a
lab and and try to measure the
ultrasonic noise I knew this it is
terrible often it really complex video
cameras and all kinds of electronic
equipment generating complex acoustic
environments the animals introducing
variability of course every building and
rooms going to have its own acoustic
features whether there's been a lab
caching in the room you know we're
increasingly using ventilated caging
because of some of the benefits it
brings but it also brings us problems so
you need to keep that in mind the micro
environment however is what actually
reaches the animal this is going to
include sources of noise that will vary
depending on how many animals are in the
cage whether you have enrichment devices
in the cage the type of caging used
static caging versus ventilated caging
is going to produce very different kinds
of noise and vibration and features we
routinely measured inside cage noise a
vibration as well as outside the cage
macro
a lot of the ultrasonic noises in the
macro-environment don't make it to the
micro they'll make it into the enemy so
I have a couple plots to show you to
demonstrate that these high-frequency
sounds in the library Ammar really
directional they they they act like
laser so you need to imagine the
echolocation occurring in a bat that
shoots at a high frequency sound it's
using that sounds behavior as it bounces
back like a laser from an object to tell
it where something is so the high
frequency sounds in a vivarium will act
like ping-pong balls it will act like
lasers as they shoot out so if you can
identify the source of the ultrasonic
noise whether it be a light or you know
a ragtop blower motor or a timer or a
computer you can you can block them
easily you can isolate them away but if
you don't know they're there you can't
do that so knowing that they're there is
the start and then fixing it is actually
pretty simple how frequent seem always
dropped dramatically with distance as
well so if you've got a light generating
70 DB of ultrasonic noise you can
actually show that 4 feet lower where
the animal is it's dropped to a level
that's not audible sometimes so knowing
the intensity is an important component
as well as the frequency so the lower
the frequency the more these sounds will
Bend and so we have to worry more about
them actually so this is just a kind of
few snapshots here some data we
collected in different in different
environments this is a typical you know
measurement from light fluorescent
lighting which is pretty typical in our
facilities is going to generate
ultrasonic noise pretty much always in
this case we've got signature sounds
here here the 20 this spot here at 22
kilohertz this would be audible to the
animal is 35 kilohertz would be audible
to the animal these these would be
problems if you hear them all day and
you might think 30 35 DB 40 DB that's
not so loud
but the typical tinnitus sufferer
experiences his tinnitus at 1520 25 dB
it's not especially
it doesn't have to be loud enough to
cause hearing loss if it's there all the
time it can be irritating
and can interfere with communication in
fact you know for example in rats we
know this 22 kilohertz region is
critical for a kind of an aversive call
so anytime you see something in the 20
to 25 kilohertz range coming from motors
which is really common frankly you worry
about it activating stress pathways
because of its acoustic similarity to a
stress call anytime you have metal keys
on your caretakers body as they enter
the room as they put them in their
pockets they will generate enormous
ultrasonic noise problems so this is
just an example of keys jangling and
again you know point out here that this
20 kilohertz frequency you you hear
everything below this so we can hear the
keys jangling but we we don't hear this
and our animals hear it really really
well in fact it used to be in the audio
genic seizure literature that the way
you would induce seizures and seizure
prone young mice would be to jingle your
keys and this high frequency component
would drive them crazy and produce an
audio genetic seizure every time so the
point here is if you use metal keys put
rubber bumpers on them and most of us go
to card systems and other you know
access systems now but if you still use
physical hard keys try to find a way to
isolate them from the animals computers
if you have computers in your vibrating
space which is increasingly common to
enter data to log data to control
telemetry systems to do any number of
things be very very very careful because
every computer that we've measured every
desktop computer especially generates
high frequency noise so this particular
these are two different computer
desktops that we've measured in a lab
this is a sudden 2 kilohertz sound it's
nearly 60 dB so conversation level is
about 60 to 70 dB so imagine that a
conversation level tone all day is there
all day long and that's what this
computer is going to do so if you bring
the animal over
for example to your desktop to give them
an injection for a blood pressure study
let's say you set him in this
environment while you're prepping and
and he's getting exposed to this tone
that maybe may be stressful you can
introduce variability and if the other
animals on the other side of the
computer the acoustics are going to be
different maybe there's a sum of the
time there's something blocking it so
it's not there so just recognize that
the variability can be great and every
computer will have a different signature
based on the electronics on the inside
so telemetry units they seem pretty you
know pretty benign right but those
systems can generate ultrasonic not as
you can see this signature here just a
couple other examples this is
frightening these are mobile temperature
and humidity meters that we all have in
our facility sometimes they're on the
wall sometimes on the countertop they
actually generate through power
switching mechanisms in the back high
frequency sound here you can see this
one this is you know 55 60 DB almost in
a high pitch area that we don't hear
basically every one of these we've
measured has that rack top fence this is
a concern for for for a lot of people
there are as many styles as there are
labs it seems but ultimately anytime you
place a motor with moving mechanical
parts above the animals you have to be
careful this is an example of what some
of these might look like about a 55 to
60 DB signature up around 40 kilohertz
so ultimately there's something in there
oscillating about 40,000 times a second
it could be power it could be bearings
going bad and you can actually measure
this over time and watch these things
age and see that the ultrasonic noise
gets greater and greater and greater and
will move lower in frequency as the
system ages and the mechanical parts get
older and older so sometimes you have to
just replace a blower motor or oil
something or replace a component if you
know it's there you can start those of
us who have wrapped our vent systems
they often have hose connections on them
make sure you routinely check those hose
connections make sure you routinely
tighten them this is an example of one
room there's quite a bit of noise coming
from this particular rack
we tightened the hose connection and it
took away a lot of that that noise
really cleaned it up dramatically let's
see I have an example here of three
different rack top vents measured at the
exhaust vent these these are all the
same manufacturer and you can see the
these three different systems or I'll
have similar mechanical properties so
they're all shooting out a 20 kilohertz
sound and a 40 kilohertz sound is
ultimately a harmonic it's the same
signal harmonic above the other one
and again we're not hearing these
signatures and the animals will be and
especially those animals right under the
rack top glory unit they're likely going
to hear it let me jump through this
because we're actually running behind
I'm gonna actually make sure I can I can
get the slides to you folks as well
because I think it's you might find it
useful I want to point this out because
in my lab actually these showed up a
couple years ago and if you ever see in
a vivarium space we're in a plan for
building or construction a format of
turning off the lights that uses
something that looks like this then you
should you should say don't do that
because this is a big problem so these
are light motion sensors so these are
designed to basically use ultrasonic
noise you can see the little speakers in
the front it'll shoot out ultrasonic
noise and measure what bounces back and
it uses that to detect movement and if
it detects movement it'll keep the
lights off if it doesn't detect
movements for a certain amount of time
you can turn the lights off so this
ultrasonic detector we found produces a
126 decibel sound it is absolutely
intense that's actually loud enough to
deafen your animals if they're close to
that for like five minutes it would be
devastating this is what it looked like
so it was about 40 kilohertz we had no
idea that sound is there because we only
hear down here in the lower frequency
area
so the fact that the fact that this area
through here I'm trying to use the wrong
tool sorry
in fact that this area through here is
producing 126 DB if you were to bring a
rat or a mouse or a dog or a cat into
that space they they would freak out
they would have the dog will be barking
at the wrong hole the cat would go nuts
the mouse if it's certain strains like
DBA early C 57 and they're really young
they're gonna have seizures and we don't
even know it's there so don't allow
those things to be put in corridors lab
spaces I've arranged bases for sure the
one particularly concerning area and a
lot of ibrehem directors and that's
don't really have control over this
sometimes there are common behavioral
research areas in those spaces but
ultimately where animals are taken to do
testing is is usually very very much
more noisy acoustically and vibratory if
this in this particular situation we're
actually measuring ultrasonic and I
lilies produced by some lights that are
directly above a open field test so this
open field test many of you've seen it
before often times there's a camera
above and and of course lights and in
this particular case there's a
ultrasonic noise present from the lights
right above the open field test imagine
if this is present in you know Morris
water maze where the animals have to
learn where the location of a platform
is if you've got a light off to one side
generating this high-frequency buzz it's
serving as a directional cue we don't
even know it's there and it's not
routine if you look in that literature
and these behavioral studies literature
they don't routinely measure these
things and know that they're there and
again we're increasingly using video
cameras and computers to monitor such
stations such testing so keep an eye out
for it cage changing stations are
notorious for producing noise and
vibration major major problems so when
you're choosing cage changing stations
please try to choose ones that are more
quiet look for people that advertise
ones that are more quiet and if you have
to put the animals in there to change
their cages
be sure to minimize the amount of time
they're in there if possible put them on
rubber mats while they're in there
because the vibration levels are
routinely enormous they're routinely
very very bad so expect animals to be
stressed for a couple hours after
meeting cages changes and it's frankly
not as likely to be do I think to the
handling of them and it is to the noise
of vibration that they got exposed to so
you know you're gonna see an acute
stress response but you're gonna see a
delayed stress response because of stuff
like this so you'll see a quarter
you know chorus Darrin response 15 20 30
minutes after a treatment like this so
very very problematical so rule of thumb
here anytime you've got rats or mice in
an environment that is complex with
computer screens computer terminals
you've got compressed gases that can
leak out we didn't even talk about that
but you know when you open a soda and
you first start to open it it squeals a
little bit before you can hear it it's
producing an ultrasonic noise and and so
anytime you have compressed oxygen co2
tanks even vacuum lines you have to
check the connections they could be
squealing causing stressors to animals
so it's remarkable how much stuff can
actually produce this information this
noise vibration that we're not even
aware is there so quickly about
vibration I'm gonna spend some time on
this again very similar to noise and
then with respect to how it induces
stress it isn't a known stressor it is
used as a stress induction model
remember that rats and mice are you know
they're basically evolved to live
underground and they don't see well so a
great way to stress them is with sound
they communicate well you sound it works
well in tongues and with vibration so it
is important ecologically to recognize
noise and vibration as an issue so there
are day-to-day vibrations that our
animals experience these are going to be
routine they're going to be there all
the time little more
the people coming in and out of the
facility at usually similar times today
they have carts they walk they may clear
denoise the slide cages and racks in and
out and move stuff predictability is a
good thing when it comes to noise and
vibration as far as the animals are
concerned but we have a lot of
day-to-day stuff we can't really control
a lot of this we don't generally know
it's there but it's it's it's there
every day there are also temporary
sources of vibration these these can be
more problematic if you think about it
because the animals can't predict when
they're gonna happen or what's going to
happen
this can include construction that comes
up all of a sudden animal starts to hear
employees or feel vibration maintenance
activities in the area and
transportation my underlying
transportation of animals because and I
have a figure to show you in a second
just the vibration induced by
transportation is some of the most
compounding that we have the vibration
levels are through the roof when you're
putting an animal on a cart and wheeling
it somewhere across the facility so
don't expect that I'm going to behave
normally for hours after that the
vibration has a lot of the same negative
impacts that noise does it can impact
breeding it can impact food intake
weight gain any number of things and
this will be species dependent it will
be level dependent dose dependent it's
kind of like noise and so you have to
know what the vibration level is you
have to know whether it's high enough to
do stress you have to know what the
frequency of that is in some cases to
know whether they can even sense it and
in humans we actually know a lot more
about vibration impacts it's been
studied more intensely we know how it
can impact all kinds of cognitive
processes sleep processes behavioral and
neurological function it is remarkably
good as a stressor for people as well
in fact OSHA has eight-hour exposure
limits just like they do with noise and
it turns out that the level that OSHA
sets as their eight-hour supposed lumen
which is 0.5 meters per second squared
this is basically a an SI standard for
or for measuring vibration acceleration
so 0.5 meters per second squared is the
standard so if you're exposed to that
for Nader for you today
OSHA says that's problem so if you're
running a Jack camera or if you're doing
anything with that level of vibration
beware at point 8 we actually have the
experience of being uncomfortable we
wanna get away from that so it turns out
that this point five level is actually
the same level known to induce stress
and other problems in animals it's
actually kind of fortunate we're lucky
there's not as much research on the
animals as people but we know that this
level is a concern and so we we keep our
eyes out for that level a threshold what
detection is similar for animals and
people for rats mice and people it's
about 0.01 meters per seconds clear so
that's the level of vibration that you
can actually tell us there that's the
threshold and that that level where we
actually engage that we actually think
something should be done as point five
meters per second see if for the same
reason we see the exposure limit in
people it's at that point that it causes
lots of biological and behavioral
impacts so that level is based on some
literature that I can share with anybody
that's interested there are a few
studies out there on this I'm just going
to highlight a couple really cool
figures that I think are interesting the
construction process is known to
activate stress pathways and animals and
this particular study Rath and
colleagues found that plasma cortical
stearin levels were elevated during
construction compared to before and
after and so it's clear that the animals
can experience this vibration and they
can respond to it and it's something we
have to worry about but not destroying
construction during many other aspects
as well so this is the figure I
mentioned earlier that I would show this
is these are vibration levels in
acceleration meters per second squared
it's small that meters per second
squared as a function of transporting
animals and this is super frightening so
that point five level that I was telling
you not it is right through here so this
point five level and then yes to me here
it's similar right through there right
so anything above that
can we know from animal and human
research can induce stress responses so
if your hand carrying the animals that's
actually going to lead to just two and a
half or seven meters per second squared
which is the best of all of our options
metal cart smaller large plastic carts
metal carts with towel and then to help
absorb some of the vibration ultimately
transporting animals is going to give
them more vibration and I'll ever in
ovarian space but in a vivarium space we
oftentimes see this point five point six
point seven even in in racks where we
see motors going bad so ultimately
that's an important area to keep an eye
on so some conclusions before we get to
some questions here so these are these
are basically overall findings from all
the labs would go into an overall
summary of what we what we think is
important to pay attention to so the
noise that we hear we use our ears right
as workers as the eyes as investigators
as facility directors we use our ears
and eyes and those to try to determine
when there's a problem unfortunately in
the facility we can't we can't rely on
that for vibration or noise the
ultrasonic noises we don't hear can have
huge impacts on our animals the
vibrations that we can't really tell are
there sometimes you can put your kit
your hand on a rack now that vibrates a
lot is that a lot enough is it not quite
enough to cause a problem you have to
know what the level is this measurement
is key documentation is key so these
noises and vibrations are ubiquitous in
our facilities every facility we've been
to has them and it's just a matter of
how bad they are are they approaching
levels of concern where you throw a red
flag up and say we have to get a new
rack motor or we have to move this rack
of animals to a new space or we have to
put a silencer on on the ventilation
system unless you know the levels you
can't really make those determinations
so the variability from lab to lab is
great from room to room is great and
even lacked a rack so it's in a single
vivarium room
you know we have seen dramatic variation
where you'll have one rack that just
vibrates violently and produces an
ultrasonic noise that is really really
damaging to the animals in that rack
especially the animals on the top level
of the rack but the next rack will be
perfectly silent will have no vibration
to speak of well below the threshold of
action and will have really little if
any ultrasonic noise some acoustic noise
of course anytime you've got a motor
around you're going to hear it but a lot
of that frequency is actually below at
the animals can hear and this is of
course in introducing a lot of
variability so we're interested in the 3
R's of course and as it relates to this
confound we know that we are putting
animals in studies that have different
exposure histories it makes no sense
that we don't document these problems
that we don't do a better job of
controlling them because it is causing
us to use more animals in our cancer
studies and diabetes studies and Studies
on everything that we do and it does
help explain some of the variability
from study to study some of the lack of
reproducibility in some models I'm
convinced it is totally a function of
this because I figure this in so many
labs now where there has been a
documented problem and we can help them
find that solution it just makes
complete sense that that would be a way
to explain some of that variability so
the basic bottom line is that we think
every facility ought to be conducting an
annual noise and vibration audit we
think it ought to be as routine as
documenting where you get your food from
and documenting that the lifetime of
works and documenting that the cages
were changed on this particular day we
think it ought to be a regular thing
that is done for the animals and and not
just for the animals but through the
science is one of these rare areas where
the Wellness of the animal also benefits
the science not an especially rare thing
it's really common right but it's if
that is the point that the the animals
wellness the benefits from understanding
these variables as does the science we
also think that in addition to
like an annual check like every room in
your facility to see where problems are
we think that you ought to collect some
data anytime you have any new
construction anytime you have remodeling
going on anytime you bring in major new
equipment or when you see problems in
behavior or breeding need to do some
checks to see what what's going on for
especially sensitive animals
particularly sensitive we recommend a 24
hour noise and vibration monitoring this
can be done now we can do this kind of
thing really actually set thresholds and
alerts it can save studies and and and
fixing or minimizing the impacts of
these variables can usually be very
simple once you find them we can isolate
them from the animals we can rotate
issues around we can even solve the
problems when we find that they're there
so I'm gonna stop there and we've got a
few minutes left to go through some
questions and answers so let's see we've
got Liana here she's going to help us
look at some questions into the box that
appears on your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so our
first question comes from Lisa if
computers are kept in animal rooms will
this affect their behavior or stress
levels so Lisa the answer to this is
that it it depends on how close the
computer is to the animals and it
depends on what the acoustic profile of
that computer is so bottom line is is
every computer we've measured will
generate some of this and it depends on
its features as to whether it'll spread
so for example that's generating a 40
kilohertz sound of 70 dB at the back of
the computer if you've got an animal
within three or four feet of that it's
going to hear it it's going to hear it
as a 40 or 50 DB sound it will drop you
know 30 or 40 dB just a few feet away so
if you're across the room the animals
not going to hear it
so it basically depends on the pitch of
the sound higher the frequency the
quicker it'll drop with distance so we
would want to know what the frequency is
and based on that we could you know put
the computer in the right place you can
also devise little deflectors that you
can put at the the event area on your
computer where the sounds coming out to
basically capture it so that it doesn't
spread so that it bounces around in a
confined space so so the answer is it
depends so Jeff asks can you recommend
or suggest measuring devices for the
ultrasonic range so there are a couple
there are a couple strategies you can
you can use I've talked to some people
about using bat detectors you can get
back detectors for you know a few
hundred dollars three or four hundred
dollars will get you a decent low level
bat detector that can tell you whether
there's an ultrasonic signal present the
problem with that detectors though
unless you're buying a very high-end one
many thousands of dollars it won't
necessarily will it won't tell you how
loud the sound is so this can create a
lot of false alarms and the point here
is if you take a bat detector into your
library in space be pointed at a light
be pointed at a blower you're gonna hear
ultrasonic noise and and you're gonna
freak out but the question is how loud
is it what's the intensity so you have
to have a calibrated system to do that
and so that's that's why you know the
higher-end equipment that we specialize
in we think is important because you can
determine how loud it is and the pitch
so it's good as a screening tool to try
to determine where their problems are
and to isolate them but to really study
the how loud it is and know whether it's
actually got an action requirement
associated with it you're gonna want the
intensity to so we rent that equipment
we don't like to sell it because we it's
hard to calibrate it's hard to keep up
so we rent that equipment and we can
help people come to those solutions
recently I was having a lot of trouble
getting my mind
so I moved them to the bottom of Iraq at
the time I was thinking that they may
they may be more comfortable in the
darker area but now I'm wondering if it
has to do with the noise produced by the
lighting since the move my breeders have
been having more larger litters do you
know of any research being done
regarding Mouse breeding and noise
induced stress so yeah Bethany the the
the top of Iraq is is bad for several
reasons you know not only are light
levels higher up there but the sources
of noise and ultrasonic noise are
usually up there as well so if you've
got the only the caging systems the the
blower units gonna be up there
generating all kinds of noise the lights
are gonna be closer so not only the
light levels but the actual ultrasonic
from the lights are going to be greater
up there but also the vibration if
you've got a blower unit mounted onto
your rack it's gonna vibrate at the top
so you know we can actually measure the
spread of vibration across Iraq and a
lot of studies or a lot of labs what we
see is that the top row of a rack will
have a vibration level above the point O
5 threshold but the bottom one will be
down around point to 0.3 so the
vibration actually dissipates as it gets
absorbed by the rack and moves down so
the top of a rack is is kind of a
notorious location and frankly you'd
probably want to put your least
important animals up there to be honest
as a quick quick and dirty way to figure
that out so without measurements and
it's impossible to know whether it was
the light or whether it was vibration or
noise but it's possible all three of
them could have had so Maddalena would
like to know is it safe to have phones
inside the facility not in the animal
rooms but in the other rooms and what
about cell phones so we've we've
measured iPhones we've measured from
some other non iPhone cell phones as
well we don't see ultrasonic sounds
coming from them everything is encased
in the phones really well so that the
ultrasonic that is present is actually
bouncing around inside the case and not
escaping well so that's a good thing
they're not generating tons of
ultrasonic noise at least from what
we've measured so far the only reason to
worry about
then would be that it might the ringer
might go off producing a relatively high
pitch sound but but that's kind of gonna
be low enough frequency it is to not be
too problematic for animals so the
bottom line is we don't really see cell
phones doing much of any any damage
measuring noise and/or vibration levels
an initial assessment of all areas
followed by measures one significant
change to facility occurs yeah we really
are starting to come to the belief after
doing this for a number of years now
that every facility is surprised and
when we come in to see what we see and
so we really think that once a year
quick noise and vibration audit is a
very smart thing to do we provide that
service and there may be others that do
as well and you might even have in-house
people that could do the vibration the
noise stuff it's usually hard to find
the ultrasonic equipment on hand even if
you have a hearing researcher on campus
but but normally the way this works we
come into a facility we'll spend a day
and just go room to room and do just an
overall check and give a report and then
we'd recommend just double checking a
year later because equipment ages and
and we have to you know worry about
blower motors getting older and
vibrating all the sudden so once a year
and then any time you have major
construction going on or any time you
bring new equipment into the lab racks
for example you'd want to check them
because you just don't know until you
measure so we think it ought to be
documented once a year at a minimum and
anytime you see significant changes in
your facility asks what do you think
about using white noise during a
behavioral task to mask other equipments
present in the room so this is routinely
done often without an awareness of the
hearing range of mice or rats so
most white noise generators that you get
I think if you go to your doctor's
office or counselor they often do this
will too
they will often do this to protect you
no human discussion
most of those noise generators are
playing sound below 500 Hertz definitely
blow a thousand Hertz so that white
noise is not really white noise that
will include high frequency it's usually
a really low pitch so what white noise
generators do in a facility or in a
behavioral environment often is make it
harder for the researcher to communicate
because it will impede their
conversation so the point is you have to
look at the frequency of the white noise
is it actually presenting sounds in the
frequency range that the rat or the
mouse can hear if so it might be useful
to mask some of those equipment noises
to make a uniform acoustic environment
you have to know the frequency range of
that sound
okay frequency of diet consumption so we
may be talking about intermittent
fasting paradigms I'm assuming in animal
models I don't know of any evidence
related to that area you expect that
with different dietary regimes
intermittent fasting for example you're
gonna see during the eating phase you're
gonna see more noise in in the in the
inside cage you know as the animals are
consuming food but I don't know the
interactions between that dietary
regimen and noise and vibration actually
I don't know of any data on that so the
key for for noise is to use a quarter
inch microphone these things tend to be
you know well north of a thousand
dollars and when you get a preamp and
and a 2 D and a computer connected to it
you know you're usually talking
somewhere in the you know eight ten
thousand dollar range for a system so we
we have some of our own custom stuff
that we make we have software that we
next
are developing we're actually developing
an app right now an iOS app with a
vibration sensing device bluetooth based
so you can put a little a little
vibration sensor inside a cage and
wirelessly on an iPad or iPhone you'll
be able to measure the vibration levels
inside there and it'll actually show you
the thresholds of action it'll tell you
whether you're at the point O five level
or below or above and you can document
that so we're actually that's gonna be
ready in the next month so we'll look
for some advertising coming out on that
because that's a really cool device that
we think will be important and a big
help for the industry otherwise you know
just using a standard noise meter to e
buy off-the-shelf
be careful because all of our you know
facilities help them Safety officers or
environmental health officers they'll
have a noise meter but they're there to
measure human hearing range noise and it
won't measure these high frequency
sounds so the minute you move to high
frequencies it becomes very complex the
microphones the behavior of the sound
the way you condition and amplify and
digitize that sound is complex so this
is why we we actually provide this
equipment for people we will rent it to
you you know we'll send it to you for a
week at a time so you can do the
measurements we get instructions on that
we we don't we don't currently really
want to sell it because it's just it
takes maintenance to take care of these
and to keep them calibrated and taken
care of and most facilities will need
this you know for a couple days a year
or any time they see a problem and so
doesn't make sense to buy expensive
piece of equipment and train somebody to
use it and then after we learn it once a
year so renting it is a pretty good
option we think so Bethany I'm going to
spitball this one because the there are
no direct comparisons experiments
directly comparing noise and vibration
on bleeding there are noise studies on
breeding their vibration studies on
breeding my my my hunch having been into
a lot of facilities measuring noise and
vibration levels when there are breeding
problems my hunch is that vibration
is probably a little more likely to
cause breathing problems because they
you know you might think that Noli is
the ultrasonic stuff because we don't
hear it it's a problem that so much of
the time a lot of that is blocked by the
caging system and doesn't reach the
animal very well but the vibration does
so if I had to guess I would I would put
it more on the vibration side as being a
problem asks vibration is highly
variable from someone studied the best
architecture and material to reduce that
and therefore lab research outcomes
architecture and materials so there
there is a lot of research on building
structure and engineering that has to do
with with noise and vibration isolation
there's there's there's entire fields
out there focused on that again most of
that is focused exclusively on human
hearing vibration seems to be pretty
similar from human to animal so if you
can isolate vibration with good
construction you should do that the
problem is macro versus micro so
building engineers and construction
firms and designers they can do a very
good job of controlling a noise and
vibration at the macro level so what
gets sent down you know a load bearing
pile what what moves from room to room
what moves from Florida wall that kind
of stuff they can do a good job load
with care but what they cannot control
is the micro noise and vibration so what
actually the room is doing what the
floor is doing and what the wall is
doing is one thing but then what makes
it through the casters in the bottom of
the rack what makes it through the
reacting to the animal so we are
introducing inside the micro space
through our through our you know
ventilated rack systems our carts that
we're putting in the facilities and our
cage changing stations we're introducing
a lot of this ourselves it's often not
in the building in fact most of that
gets filtered out by the time it gets to
the animals to be honest
whether it's Millie's or vibration
so I think we have time for one more
question and that will be from Richard
he says many facilities are moving to
RFID tags on cages to conduct census do
you have any information on the amount
of noise generated by the RFID readers
so I the radio frequency ID stuff the
the frequencies of those RF signals are
so high as to not be to not have an
impact on the animals as far as we're
aware the readers themselves I don't
know because they're gonna be mechanical
instrument it's not unlike a cell phone
they may generate some some high pitch I
I would have to measure more than one to
know that for sure I have not seen them
yet produced noise but I think I've only
measured from maybe one of these things
so I wouldn't know for sure unless I
measured so I'd be be careful but I
wouldn't I wouldn't assume that it would
actually send an email to dr. Turner you
know on your screen I'd like to thank
our sponsor that reads for making
today's educational webcast possible and
then before we go I want to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing for six
months from today's live event you'll
receive an email from laberd's letting
me know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event any
closing comments yeah thank you very
much for your attention
know that we it over science labs we've
dedicated ourselves to understanding
this noise and vibration problem and
helping you to measure it and understand
it yourselves so please let us know if
we can help you in any way we can
dispatch our field technician to come
on-site and do a day audit any time we
can do consults remotely we can do
web training to staff and look forward
to hearing from some of you especially
as we have our wireless device coming
out for vibration it will be a neat tool
that I think will will help refine our
models greatly we'll be able to measure
inside the cage vibrational levels let
us know if we can help you with any
equipment realm and any advice so thanks
for your attention